welcome to the smite God reveal for
Kumbhakarna the sleeping giant in smite
kumbhakarna snoozes his way to victory
as a guardian do you hear it that
distant Rumble like thunder across the
mountains like pitched battle from miles
away like a stampede of elephants across
the plains no it is none of these things
that rumble you hears the bellowing
snoring baa karna the sleeping giant
quick with a laugh honest with friends
the devastating in battle
Kumba karna embodies the traits of a
hero but loyalty to his tyrant brother
Ravana often leads him to the wrong side
so jovial and pious is he that when
granted a boon by Brahma
khumba karna wished to take in dress
place and rule the heavens Indra was
jealously threatened convinced Brahma
would let the good nature giant usurp
him and magically twisted khumba karna
stalling at the last second instead of
asking for Indra sana Indra seat
he asked for midre asana to sleep now
that rumbling you hear it is not his
snores but khumba Karnas mighty roar or
was that a yawn
khumba Karnas passive is called sleepy
Kumbhakarna does not die when he reaches
zero health instead he falls asleep he
will awaken after several seconds at 25%
health and mana unless hit by a set
amount of basic attacks his first
ability is called throw back Kumba karna
sleepily runs forward if he hits an
enemy he stops and deals damage if the
enemy is a minion he throws them dealing
more damage his second ability is called
groggy strike Kumba karna smashes down
damaging all enemies in front of him all
enemies hit are also routed his third
ability is called mighty yawn Kumba
karna lets out a mighty yawn that
mesmerizes all enemies in the range if
awakened early enemies are slowed khumba
karna may use this ability while asleep
Goomba Karnas ultimate is called epic
uppercut Kumba karna moves forward
delivering a massive melee swing that
knocks the enemy directly in front of
him into the air when the enemy lands it
deals area damage and causes knock up
two enemies nearby
in this first scenario kuba karna pushes
middle lane against on who are arriving
from the jungle for a gank the Allied on
who are pins his enemy counterpart with
a shifting sands and impale combo just
as mercury arrives with sonic boom
sending the enemy flying with epic
uppercut Kumba gets the kill in this
second fight khumba karna blinks into
mid lane for a gank sending in box
flying with epic uppercut khumba sets up
Kraken combo for Poseidon as encore
impales the howler monkey God several
additional abilities and a basic attack
by on [ __ ] takedown moonbots in this
final fight Kumba karna secretly watches
as the enemy team goes for the gold fury
blinking in khumba mesmerizes nearby
enemies with mighty yawn sending Agni
flying with epic uppercut Kumba steals
the gold fury with fists of the gods
agnese rough landing aids khumba and
getting a kill as the majority of the
remaining enemies are taken down as the
sleeping giant Kumba karna drowsily
smashes through all who stand in his way
starting him off with throw back can
provide khumba with a hefty kit of a
poke waveclear and - when in a tight
spot next picking up mighty yawn can
make Kula a great asset to his Lane
partner with the mesmerize and slow
potential from there the priority shift
- epic uppercut throw back mighty yawn
groggy strike also introduced in this
patch is the scarlet coven Isis skin
thanks for watching the smite God reveal
for khumba karna the sleeping giant
you